[Music]  now to some traffic news here at noon  there are some slow downs on the strip  today because of the construction  project that of course we've been  telling you about in the mornings and  it's happening through wednesday at 6  p.m traffic from las vegas boulevard  near sahara will be taken down to one  lane in either direction a detour is set  up today to enter the sahara casino from  paradise while the main entrance is  closed so drivers are encouraged to find  other ways around to  to get around that slow down that one  lane it can be a headache  and heads up for those who take a desert  in on your daily commute  it is closed in both directions from  sand hill to boulder highway now through  saturday for a construction project  drivers are asked to use alternate  routes